I'm Ryan, I'm 14.
I'm Alex, I'm 12.
Welcome to our crib!
This is where all the fishing happens.
This over here is an underwater theme.
I chose this because I love fishing.
This is a sunken ship.
This is where I sleep.
These three fish are my three favorite fish.
Redfish.
Snook.
Tarpon eating small fish.
There's a guy up there trying to catch a tarpon with a lure.
Redfish.
Tarpon.
Another tarpon.
That's me and a trout.
That tree over there is a mangrove tree.
It's common in Florida and there's usually a vast cornucopia of fish over there.
Over here is my treasure chest.
This is where I store my valuables.
And there's a hidden light over here.
It turns on the dock lights.
And this is my desk.
I do most of my homework here.
And that's my brother, Alex.